foreign
that pain
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to write the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting and crying would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day Barry
now
I went back in time to save my parents
but instead
I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die
to change the future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
these scars we have
make us who we are I'm not about to go
back and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
no matter what we do
we're not going to be able to fix this
no
nobody dies
foreign